welcome to LED live this is the show
where we expose darkness with the light
of Christ but guys what if the darkness
isn't really that dark anymore like more
practically what if Kanye West walked
into your church what would you do find
out on this episode of LED live next to
me brother Sam Bible study I think we
should invite Kanye on the show you know
Kanye watching water show with dark
man I feel the skepticism you know I've
been seeing this stuff about how he's
he's a Christian I see a lot of people
promoting it as a good thing and I'm
watching I'm seeing just how it's going
on in the church and I'm just like I
don't know I haven't heard him tell his
testimony the videos actually labeled
Kanye West's testimony and all I see is
a bunch of singing and there's actually
there's no praying there's no greater
man there's no word it's just music and
it's just a feeling he's saying some
good things you know
praise God or whatever but I want to
hear his testimony and I think he's
probably could be genuine and is just
learning believe me I was not changed
overnight I mean my walk people wouldn't
even know as a Christian four years
after I was a Christian and the more I
studied you got to get in that word but
when you're in there then you get
convicted about things yeah I think he
needs some Bible studies you know I
think it's interesting because we just
discussed a very high profile person
that literally was leaving their faith
and here's something that's sort of like
on the opposite like a very high profile
person that was clearly we don't know
what side of the fence he well we
probably do know what side of the fence
he was coming out on and now he's
totally coming out as a follower of
Christ I think this is really
interesting
have you guys heard of Kanye West's son
services yes yeah have you seen any of
the clips yes what do you think right
off the bat it's like you know anytime
anybody's had a conversion experience I
don't want to like discount or but I'll
have to admit I'm a little bit skeptical
especially seen as much as he's been
with jay-z and all the Colton you know I
mean he's always throwing that are you
judging by association like what's going
on you know what I I kind of am judging
by his fruit okay if I look at what kind
of things he's been producing like
clearly the cover of The Rolling Stone
magazine with a crown of thorns around
his head to me seems blasphemous so
anytime somebody that's been like that
and is now coming out and in public and
and sort of renouncing his old life and
having a Christ following well I'd like
to see him renounce his old life I
haven't seen anything like that that's
the thing it's you know I was gonna go
that same angle by their fruits you
shall know them so a perfect example of
that in the Bible is fds when Zacchaeus
came to Christ and Christ ministered to
him give Zacchaeus immediately realized
okay things need to change and from then
on out he started returning the money
that he took by corruption it's the same
kind of principle here if you've led a
life that was contrary to Christ
contrary to biblical principles then you
should start to see a turnaround and he
should start to recant some of those
things try to undo some of those things
and of course only time will tell where
that happens or not yeah there's a
pretty recent thing and we do see him on
stage at church that's that's the first
step right and I'm super hopeful I mean
really honestly God can win anybody amen
I mean you think about like
Nebuchadnezzar you know head of Babylon
it's really interesting when when when
that prophecy was given to the
Israelites basically saying listen
you're not following what I'm telling
you to do coming from God God actually
says my servant Nebuchadnezzar this is
way before God even one Nebuchadnezzar's
heart so you know the head of Babylon
literally was won over to the kingdom of
God
I'm hopeful I would like to see this
play out in a good way
on the flipside you could also look at
this from the perspective of Daniel
chapter three and there was a world
power and he was trying to get everybody
to bow down to the image right everybody
to worship the same way yeah and one of
the primary methodologies was the four
that was through music yes at the so it
would be a perfect opportunity to get
everybody on the same page and going in
the same direction all for the wrong
reason okay we know that the the final
deceptions gonna be of a religious order
and how if if the devil has spent all of
his time you know having people like
this in the public eye you know
discredit Christianity and sort of show
you the opposite view and now all of a
sudden it's like he's gotta flip the the
the general mindset of people I mean how
is everybody gonna sign up in a
religious order so yeah this is
interesting music is the devil's
specialty you said an important point
Keith by their fruits you will know them
now Kanye West isn't the only one who
has proclaimed himself to be a Christian
I mean you have Justin Bieber the
Kardashians posting pictures of them
praying which is great but at the same
time you're looking at their lifestyle
it doesn't really line up with biblical
Christianity why is it people pray and
lots of religions pray yeah that's true
so praying is not an evidence that
you're a Christian praying is just
evidence that you're reaching out to
something beyond yourself Wow so it may
seem that Kanye West Sunday service have
kind of come out of nowhere and in a
sense they have to the public eye but
it's actually been going on for quite
some time
it's October already and Kanye West
started to go public with his Sunday
services since January of 2019 but to
get even more of a backstory his wife
has made a public that Sunday service
kind of started off as therapy for Kanye
West Kanye started this I think just to
heal himself and made it it was a really
personal thing and it was just friends
and family and he has had an amazing
evolution of being born again I don't
know if you guys know but
has been diagnosed with bipolar disorder
so and Kanye West has said a lot has had
a big opinion about music and its role
in in just our physiology even light
therapy and all these things so it
wasn't surprising that he dealt he
delved into this to help him mentally
physically and I don't know maybe
someone noticed it and it started to get
popular but now it's in the public eye
um as I said it's October he actually
just had his last Sunday service last
Sunday in New York in Queens New York
he's been going from city to city I
believe it started in Coachella at
Coachella his family's gone to Detroit
hotel II meaning they're like the music
festivals oh yes that's really
interesting
it is she was kind of like the music
festival and a lot of people that are
involved in that have math need to do it
this China reached the world man yeah
that's he's trying to go right into the
darkness let's hear what happened last
Sunday he was in New York over the
weekend specifically yesterday uh he was
in Queens on Sunday morning in Jamaica
at the greater Allen AME Cathedral
Church of New York well he had his
Sunday service he also was um uptown
last night for a screening of his
IMAX film Jesus is king at the United
Palace Theater is Jesus king of
something yeah
know me sure King the king I don't I
don't feel that included I'm in the
Kanye album well that's cuz you're
Jewish right so I I can do religious
stuff right like I've listened to many
projects that are and I enjoy things
around people if you've listened to
hip-hop your whole life right there's
always spirituality but when you start
getting into straight-up having a church
service on stage where it's like let me
put it this way I can go to church I'm
not taking communion well see Kanye was
it trying to be a limit Kanye is not
targeting it's not he's nice isn't
for you who is he targeting it's
targeting people who love Jesus in
church and gospel you um said hmm that's
what was targeted too so if you feel
left out it's probably on purpose and I
and I have to
prepare to stay left out because he also
announced that he's never making secular
music yeah that's right
so crawl to the glory of God man Jesus
King gospel look man this is great for
gospel though if you make gospel music
and you're a gospel music fan this
attention to the genre I'm super excited
about this album also still hip-hop I'm
told he wrap it yo let's shout October 2
all the Jewish people's out there man
Happy New Year I'm saying yeah man look
Jesus may not be the Messiah but he
could still be king check out the Kanye
West Jesus is king album yeah I've heard
for $150 you too could show your love of
Jesus with a sweatshirt with his face
look man Jesus was Jewish men still are
he's definitely opening up conversations
what do you guys think oh what you just
saw it's interesting that he's observed
that you know the Kanye is really coming
out and he's not really trying to market
to everybody he's really to marketing
just to the Christians like that that
was kind of an interesting concept that
he's targeting them and sort of speaking
only to them it's not for everybody kind
of a thing yeah I mean counties probably
got enough money to last forever so if
he's really gonna sell out for Christ's
he'd just go all the way instead of
trying to bridge the gap and all this
you know 150 dollars for a sweatshirt
that has a black Jesus on it yeah almost
interesting yeah that he's kind of
picking up on this like you know it's a
marketing thing whereas it's like now if
you were just excited about God you know
you'd be like whatever let me just get
this word out there so you call it my
website well he send you a free t-shirt
that's good money he's got like in the
shirts that are not dude I've seen him
there bleach spilled sweat shirt with
one font like one color font across the
hip looks that's what made it kind of
suspect to me like I have no doubt in my
mind that he was probably using this for
therapeutic purposes even before this
came to the public eye there were Sunday
service rehearsals that were done in
private and he would invite choirs and
all these things but now it's out for
everyone it's like a tour he's bouncing
from city to city he's selling his lion
of holy spirit clothing and all and
Jesus's face for like $200 and upward
you know what I mean like tough yeah
this is tough looking looking at it all
yeah cause it could be like the next
best movie like the next Passion of
Christ
you know that's kind of controversy
about that too but right what's that
that TJ said he's like said something
about Jesus was not the Messiah or Jesus
doesn't have been damn aside he's a good
King is personable yeah well he was just
saying it to the Jewish guy he might not
be your Messiah but he's the king that
was called Jesus King but yeah that's
kind of questionable for a Christian to
say I'd say that bothers me a lot of it
you know we're moved on to the Marchetti
merchandising marketing phase and
everything's so expensive like get you
Jesus money yeah marketing I think
they're also missing the point because
Christianity isn't just for one group of
people it's supposed to be spread for
everyone available to everyone we're
gonna get more into what is actually
included in these Sunday services but
this shouldn't really be a target
audience or like a targeted genre in my
opinion I think if you have a message
especially when it comes to Christianity
it should be catered for everyone Kanye
West is bringing his Sunday service to
the masses via the big screen
[Music]
West will release a documentary called
Jesus's King on IMAX October 25th the
movie was filmed over the summer in the
Arizona desert the film follows West and
a team of musicians as they lead Sunday
services in cities like Chicago Atlanta
and Detroit and at Coachella
he's also held many of the services near
his home in Calabasas
I mean its documentary I'm really
curious as to what this is gonna be
about because right now it just looks
like a extended music video yeah what
there's interviews with him and you know
a testimony drops yeah I mean that's
actually I've been searching for an
interview where he speaks up on his own
services I have yet to find it well
happening today Kanye West is bringing a
twist on gospel hip-hop to Detroit he'll
be performing a free concert at the
Aretha Franklin at the theater 7 Action
News reporter Matthew Smith is live with
more on today's big event Matthew the
show sold out of tickets in a blink of
eye basically so what's it gonna look
like out there out today packed in a
word for sure right the doors gonna open
at 11 o'clock here at the amphitheater
the show starts at noon and yeah it sold
out because there are free tickets that
there were so few everybody wanted to
get them it took just the snap of a
finger for all of them to go away so we
expect this area to all be packed with
people trying to scalp or buy their way
and this without a doubt is the hottest
ticket in town should be phenomenal
spiritual fan superfan fans lining up
early Thursday hoping for tickets at the
Aretha Franklin theater quickly learning
the show it actually be sold completely
online and seconds after opening for
online sales boom two thousand plus
people in line for the 2,000 seat
amphitheater
[Music]
those who have seen the show pop up pals
we're calling it life-changing and the
show that seemed to come out of nowhere
well the only hint was an online casting
call earlier this week and was trending
in Michigan by the time tickets went on
sale online leading to excitement one
Canadian student Noah rego told us he
bought a plane ticket from $500 for this
trip to see the show
know his best bet is to buy a ticket at
a markup after all he's already booked
it and he is missing classes in class
hopefully he finds his way in if you
were even gonna be in the vicinity down
here by the Detroit River no parking is
going to be at a premium today why well
not only is the amphitheater down here
but take a look across the street oh
yeah
the circus is in town so it will be a
literal circus looking for parking down
here by the rents and over by the river
make sure you pack a little bit of
patience again the doors open at 11:00
the show is at noon so expect that to
start early and extend through the early
afternoon at least we are live in
Detroit this morning Matthew Smith 7
Action News that's gonna be one eventful
lunch hour down by the river today
without a doubt but you know something
they're gonna get a good show yeah yeah
they're not exaggerating tickets sold
out in 18 minutes yeah so a lot of
people are paying attention to this I
mean to even know that he's in your area
and it's you know he's gonna be giving
one of these Sunday services and that
your online waiting for those tickets
I mean that's that's that's a lot of
people probably just paying attention to
this on the opposite side of him
charging a lot for his shirts it's a
free concert that's true 2,000 people
are coming to sit in that girl said it
changed my life I mean it's it's
basically like a tent revival in your
town that packed out 2,000 people in 18
minutes yeah kind of good I'm gonna say
yes and no yes it's like a tent revival
and it's bringing people but it's really
only bringing people because of
celebrity status
it's my question is where are those
people during Sunday service the rest of
the week are they is excited
to come to church are they excited to
praise God are they singing those
praises to Jesus anyway every week every
day you know are they having are they
having that experience with Christ every
day or are they just on the bandwagon
because it's Kanye it's true because he
did a Sunday service in Atlanta I think
a couple of weeks ago and they said that
people were showing up like literally in
the morning 600 people when they say
that a church for the doors to be opened
because they wanted to get in there and
get a seat and see this this thing that
Kanye West is doing but are you doing
that with your pastor are you sure are
you excited to come to church because of
what you're gonna learn there or is it
just because this this novelty is
because I guarantee you they don't
normally have that problem from week to
week right yeah the pastors coming up
and let me by so I can open the doors
this morning so yeah but I know I know
it's hard to be like super it skeptical
I I can only imagine if like Paul you
know he's running around killing
Christians in the early start of
Christianity and then all of a sudden he
gets flipped and everybody's like no you
don't invite that guy oh boy he's in our
town you know and so you know he's he's
to me he's one of the greatest New
Testament writers and he's gonna be in
heaven and people are gonna be walking
around going no way dude the guy that
was like killing people is here but
think about the story your own testimony
the problem child the first one do drugs
in all this trouble came up T and said
come to my house I'm gonna show you what
God did in my life and you were
intrigued by that and went that's right
you weren't really seeking for God and
it took this life changing and
transformation so you know it could be
like this influential person we've seen
obsess oh my soul oh the devil we've
seen him dress up like Jesus and mockery
his life has changed I want to go see
let's say Israel maybe but he's
merchandising $200 sweatshirts office
and to me if you really have something
to say you're really concerned about
reaching other people and conversion why
isn't he talking about his testimony and
talking about how Christ changed his
life this or that I'm holding the
concert and charging money
our box for sweatshirts sure I wonder
what's the first thing that comes into
his fans head when he's like I'm a
Christian but before he says call me
ease us and I'm God you ask me who I am
I told you I am God so this seems to be
that that contradiction that conflict
and he has yet to renounce any of the
things he said in past is there sorry
that he literally blaspheme Jesus I
think you know publicly if he comes out
in in whatever interviews and and says
hey look man I got involved in some
seriously occult stuff because in his
testimony I remember hearing a little
bit of it where he talked about like the
devil showed him every single shiny
object I mean he was trying to entice
him over to to his way if you sign up
with this you I'll give you Fame I'll
give you money I'll give you houses he
even said that and then he goes but God
is better than all of this for radical
obedience to you we're not asking you're
not asking us to do the least you know
people like well at least I'm how we
don't do the least when he did the most
[Applause]
[Music]
I've seen him work miracles in my life
work miracles in our life
you know the devil present so many
flashes on shiny objects I've seen
everything that the devil could have
showed you via TV videos car dealerships
jewelry so I'm hoping that literally
maybe he's had some kind of conversion
and you know maybe he you know old
habits die hard he's he's a marketer I
don't know and you're in your Christian
experience that you think of John the
Baptist what was his message repent for
the kingdom of heaven is at hand do a
Jesus same thing repent for the kingdom
of heaven is at hand Peter preaches to a
bunch of people he's like repent right
and be baptized as acts 19 chapter three
and then you get to all the way down to
Revelation you know it's the same kind
of repentance message it's all the way
it's repentance turn from what you're
doing do something else it looks like
the same thing repackaged that's right
if you look at the life of Paul I mean
Paul was literally saying you know die
old man and maybe this new creation in
Christ so I think you're right you're
hitting the nail on the head if he's
coming out in the public and talking
about righteousness forsaking the ways
of the world and doing that then that's
that's that's kind of hard to fight
against but if it's just like all you
got to do is sign up and you know you're
gonna have a endless life with God in
heaven and you could still be the same
yeah that to me isn't a message for that
I think it's a different a difference in
how things are said though and what
light they're put in how you just put it
you gave examples of Jesus and Peter and
all these you took people back to the
Bible that has yet to be done at least
from the videos that have been released
that has yet to be done from Kent
Kanye's standpoint he's been given a mic
and he has a message to share but I
haven't seen him really pointing people
to the word to the truth in that sense
it's just been look at me this is what
I've gone through and that kind of thing
which I'm not bashing him than that I'm
just saying
he seems to be new at this yeah I'd say
to be fair does they've been giving a
platform to talk to millions of people
and I don't know how much truth he
actually knows yeah I hope there's a
pastor wherever he's doing these sermons
at I hope there's a pastor saying hey
Kanye I really want to study with you I
wanted you to get on the same page as us
you know that I get that he could be at
a lack of truth but a repent is like
level it's ground zero wait so we're
talking first up here right
you have your encounter with Christ do
you get on your knees you accept Jesus
into your heart and you repent that's
that's pretty much foundation of
Christianity so if if we've missed that
step that's where I'm calling question
Kim Kardashian has actually been quite
outspoken about her not only Sunday
service but her husband's and tensions
surrounding it you know people always
ask well what are you worshipping and
what is this it is a Christian service
like a musical ministry it is you know
they they talk about Jesus and God and
it doesn't you know he doesn't have his
like 501 3 C yet but you know to make it
an official Church but it is for God and
and it's a Christian Church I think that
was sometimes people are like well what
is this and what did they what are they
doing but it started off healing for him
and now it's become something that he
just really wants to share for everybody
else I want to go back to what you're
saying about music bringing this one
world religion together you know as we
see in this picture it's very Catholic
imagery and and we see like the Pope
who's trying to
he always has like these annual
gatherings where like all the religions
come together he's making commercials
already saying we all worship the same
God
Hollywood molds our culture and makes
things acceptable and did you guys see
that what is that the met Gallup that
was called was everything yeah the theme
was specifically yeah like it was
actually sin I say actually a
fashionable people dressing up as
potpourri yeah his wife was there he
wasn't he I think he was working on his
album but everyone was wearing like Pope
hats and angel wings and gold and
Madonna I mean like Mary you know and
Jesus and all that but it's like they're
almost like making Catholicism trendy
and I've seen even a couple years back
like little Wayne and stuff like wearing
the rosary and I started seeing people
wear it and stuff so I don't know man I
mean he does have mother Mary so I'm
saying you know I must say this is from
the the yeezus tour this is 2013
yeah so this is almost a mockery of
Christianity then no no no it's not so
he was kind of Christian sort of back
then as well well he grew up Christian
just there's a lot of people in the pop
right but remember seeing those those
clips of him being like I am God you
know what's awesome about Christianity
we're allowed to portray God we're
allowed to draw an image of him we're
allowed to make movies about him other
religions you're not allowed to do that
that's really what's awesome about
Christianity now this really really
spoke to me because I'm just like yeah
that's so true you can see it in movies
you can see the TV shows I'm going back
to the show Sabrina where they had the
Buffy met and all of that and the
Satanic groups are like no take this
down this is copyrighted and you're
putting in the wrong light but there's
so many shows with Christian themes
talking about Christianity
so sacrilegious and Christians actually
supported this stuff in certain
situations he's like well that's what's
awesome about Christianity like if you
just do plays and you know portrayed in
whatever
like one of the most watched TV shows
called Lucifer is watched by Christians
like you know I miss that episode go
back check it out they don't have a
problem having God slams they're gonna
still watch content that's like that
yeah other religions that's a big no-no
so going back to 2013 he could have very
well have been a Christian doing this
and would have felt fine because that's
what's so great about Christianity you
can just go up there and portray it and
slam it and if that's the case he's it
looks like he's pushing Catholicism
making it look cool or whatever trendy
so you know Kanye has been calling
himself Jesus for the past few years
interesting he has an image of death all
right but then sort of rebranding the
name Jesus but it's like and his friend
jay-z do you know what he has reached
out of himself as oh interesting fact
you found about that song right oh yeah
that song that you were just singing
Kanye wrote that song and he also
produced it
because if jay-z calls himself Jehovah H
to the Izzo V to the izz-a then Kanye
would R yeah jay-z's basically like God
Kanye signed underneath him because
himself Jesus so it's like God the
Father God the Son it's interesting I
can't wait to take this over no no no
let's come in on this okay but it's a
crucifixion staying you a statue of
Kanye on Hollywood Boulevard was an
undergrad pop that up but we didn't
authorize it no no but but it's
interesting that the artist is is
obviously reading something from my own
yeah yeah serious but he's you know
portraying himself as Jesus and he's got
his arms out in a crucifixion pose he's
got a crown of thorns around his head
and the fact that he's an idol I mean I
think artists always pick up on these
little
is in life and and they they you know
illustrate them
so he's illustrating something that ya
Kanye is an idol the money is calling
himself Jesus he's put his these ideas
out there he's clearly said he believes
he's a God when someone comes up and
says something like I am a god everybody
says who does he think he is I just told
you who I thought I was Oh God
[Music]
so this is interesting title false idol
right yeah you know I remember reading
an article one time with Natalie Portman
she was reading to her kids the story of
the Israelites and they were getting to
the place where you know God was giving
the Ten Commandments and they started
talking about false idols and she was
telling her kids that like the statue
that they give at the at the Oscars is a
false idol I thought it was not
interesting for my mom somebody that was
very you know this is when the yeah
actually popped up right before the
Oscars kind of a little jab an Oscar
Xena I love it they call they titled it
false idol I just think that's hilarious
man that's so true that's a false idol
of God he's wearing a chain necklace and
that's what he really does yeah like
he's almost making it marketable or
fashionable like you said Wow
and here is it this is an album of his
or he's on a cross like I mean I hope
he's telling his fans that I can burn
these things yeah no you stayed quiet on
this yeah that's what I'm saying that's
what bothers me is you don't hear zip
about this the Word of God says many
will come in my name saying they are
Christ yeah one of his fans also came up
with the Kanye Bible have you guys heard
of that place
all the words of God or emphasis or no
way with Kanye and yeezus so you know
yeah they have a picture that so
including the three hundred three
hundred words social commentary on a
religion and spectacle of media icons in
the 21st century
I'd be interesting to be messing with
the Bible yeah actually we're going to
see if life is imitating that art or
putting art that's out there that's kind
of imitating life like the maître then
the matrix came out they actually had a
matrix Bible right Oh Star Wars as a
Bible because some people are taking
that like it's the Bible so the world is
responding to that in that way so the
fact that somebody would make a Bible
sort of with Kanye's face on it tells me
something about what Kanye is putting
that image out there though exactly it's
it's like whatever you you wonder if
people are getting the right
message well they're getting the right
message because whatever he's putting
out that's how people are in starts out
I am on God
everybody says who does he think he is I
just told you who I thought I was Oh God
I just told you that's who I think I am
if he doesn't say anything he's got to
know this exists yeah he doesn't say
anything about this yeah to me it's
almost like it doesn't even matter what
but it is certainly back to what Keith
brought up in the very beginning is
literally like listen if he knows this
is out there he's aware that he's put
these ideas out there or whatever
he should be literally publicly going
listen this is blasphemous towards God
clear that look rid of this thing and
have nothing to do with this because I
was I was blinded and here's what the
truth is then I think it's his moral
responsibility totally to actually use
his public forum for the truth and say
this is false so let's talk about the
Christians response to this because this
is not just Kanye there are other people
who are probably in his same position
who have pasts and now are saying hey
you know I've been converted I am a
Christian and they're walking into the
church they're on fire for the Lord now
they want the platform they're using the
platform that they have what is the
Christians response what is the
Christian who's looking to them yes
response I think what this really tells
me as well is the world is having a
problem with discernment really as we
are getting closer and closer to the
ends I believe that things are gonna get
massively confusing and the only way to
really balance and understand truth and
not get kicked off in any of these sort
of weird tangents is to literally build
your foundation on the Word of God what
is the word of God say it because then
you can balance whatever Kanye's telling
the public or whatever he's putting in
his messages or whatever like this if it
doesn't speak from that word of God it's
because there's no light in it I think
it's the same by their fruits you all
know them I mean don't get so wrapped up
in the celebrity okay that you just like
fall down at their feet and God
every word that they say you need to
watch from a distance and and be
discerning because you never know what
direction people are gonna play I mean
right now to me this looks like a huge
marketing ploy that's what it looks like
he's just going after a Dimmick a
different demographic that he knows he
can cash in on because Christians are
intensely loyal when it comes to their
media so if you're onboard with Jesus
they'll be onboard with you and they you
can
I mean Hollywood hires marketing
companies to specifically market to
Christians and other faith-based groups
because they know if we get in the niche
we've got the niche and they'll respond
by and large to whatever we're putting
out there is looking you know as long as
you you know put the Jesus stamp on it
so to me it looks like that's what's
happening over here it's it's got the
Jesus stamp okay good and it's Kanye
even better let's eat it up at two
hundred dollars right here I think we
need to pray for this individual as well
like whatever side of the fence he's
truly on and coming at and it's hard to
know looking on it from the outside only
what the media is showing you all of the
hype that goes into all this machine
it's difficult to try to way through the
facts but if he really is having a
genuine conversion experience I mean he
needs help he's probably surrounded
himself with evil people and so you know
to really pray that that God gets a hold
of his heart because someone like this
could be powerful you see how many
people are responding to this already
what if he was really to go out there
and promote the truth like the real
truth aiming people back at the Bible
telling people you know go build your
foundation on the Word of God nothing
else he could win a lot of hearts he
could do a lot of good yeah that's my
prayer really that he he stays
consistent because time will tell and
that he does push in Jesus you know
in this fullest form to the masses so I
guess the word to the Christian is watch
right because you don't know what's
gonna happen with this and it could it
could go two ways right you could either
be really good for Christianity or it
could be really bad and deceptive in in
the meantime I'd say watch don't get all
wrapped up in it I think the reason why
celebrity Christians are so appealing is
because their whole life is on display
you know we can get it we can get
invited to a church and share all our
secret sins and all everything that
nobody knew about our past but we've
seen these people what they're doing you
know we've seen them pose nude or
whatever you know it's like all out
there for everybody to see and for them
to be like I'm a Christian now like wow
it's but all the more reason to be that
much more responsible with your message
that's right yeah because you're still
another guy yeah because you are in the
public eye yeah all right well thank you
guys so much for watching
hey leave a comment down below a comment
of encouragement to people like Kanye
people who are going through a
conversion experience and remember to
continue to pray for him and others and
to look to Christ as your person for
example and authority and not to those
around you if you're looking at these
t-shirts you're like oh those are so
cool I want one well they're available
right down there in that bar take a look
I'll leave a like they're not $200
please comment it's free it's their red
button down below and share this to as
many people as possible it really helps
us out check out our patreon for behind
the scenes on episodes like this and we
will see you guys next week on LED live
bye bye
[Music]